I hope you have your puzzling cap and
sensible shoes on because we're going to
delve into the story of Uncharted and
its protagonist Nathan Drake over three
videos so you'll be all caught up for
uncharted 4 here's the first game in the
series uncharted drake's Fortune our
story begins with Nathan Drake
uncovering the coffin of his ancestor
the Explorer Sir Francis Drake he's
joined by journalist Elena Fisher who's
recording the events for a documentary
as Nathan suspects the Francis's body is
gone but the coffin does contain a
mostly complete diary which points to El
Dorado the city of gold so Elena is
pumped to tell the world about the
discovery but Nate would prefer to go
away so naturally he and suddenly ditch
her classic Nate
now remember when I said the diary was
mostly complete that's because a page
had gone missing a Matt page the points
to the treasure thereafter
luckily Nate finds it inside an oddly
placed Nazi u-boat where the pair have a
run-in with Gabriel Roman a competing
treasure hunter and all-round uncool guy
who's hired a bunch of mercs led by
archaeologist Atok Navarro and
Indonesian pirates led by Eddie Rajah
hold rival the two were held up outside
the boat and Nate is forced to hand over
the map
Roman then shoots Sully totally
solidifying that he is an uncool guy and
Nate ends up having to leave him behind
escaping into the jungle Nate runs into
Elena and they jet off to El Dorado
which they believed to be in an island
buried in the Pacific Nate seems to get
over his dead body really quickly but I
guess he's blinded by treasure and cute
reporter so we'll let it slide
unfortunately the plane crashes and
Elena and Nate are separated but after a
period of serial pirate murdering and
perilous war scaling Nate discovers that
Sir Francis had gone to the fort's Tower
it's here where Drake runs into Eddie
Basha who imprisons him and demand his
assistance in finding the treasure well
luckily for Drake Elena swoops in to
save the day with a well-timed escape
plan and a car the two discovered the
gold statue there after was moved
further inland and then Elena spots
Sully alive and
namely working with Navarro and Roman
plot-twists that turns out to not be the
case and Nate rescue Sully who explains
the Drake's diary blocked the bullet an
unexpected bridge collapse also causes
Elena to decide whether she wants to
save her own life all her camera and it
does take her a while but she opts for
the former Nate is making his way
through the islands monastery in search
of the treasure vault when he overhears
Eddie telling Roman the island is cursed
while Nate has murdered a lot and I mean
a lot of people by this point it seems
there may be something even worse to
worry about Nate and Elena discover a
subterranean level of the monastery
where they run into a terrified Eddy
being chased by mutated humans who
ultimately make short work of him the
pair escaped yet another dire situation
and find themselves in a Nazi submarine
base when nate discovers both the
spaniards and germans sort the statue
but learned that it was cursed and
spawning the mutants who were actually
descendants of the original spanish
colonists turns out our old friend
francis was actually trying to keep the
statue on the island
knowing how dangerous it was but the
mutants killed him off understandably
bummed about his ancestors untimely
demise Nate leaps his family heirloom
Francis Drake's ring on his body
Elena naturally is captured by Roman and
Navarro and Nate and Sully fight to save
her they discover Elena and Roman with
the statue and Navarro urges Roman to
open it he does so and inhales the dust
from the rotting mummy corpse of El
Dorado shockingly said dust is not good
for you and Navarro kills Roman as he
begins mutating Navarro reveals that he
intended to sell the mutagen as a weapon
the whole time quite rightly pointing
out that he is in fact the only person
on the island who knew what was going on
ahead of time Navarro attempts to
airlift the statue off the island while
angry mutants swarm his men and Nate
hitches a ride on the statue hanging
from the helicopter
Elena is held captive in continuing this
game's bail of unreliable vehicles
Elena's sort of accidentally kills the
pilot causing the chopper to crash into
a conveniently located cargo ship Nate
what he does best and shoots a lot of
dudes before knocking Navarro out he
then shoves the helicopter off the
vessel which drags both the Statue and
Navarro down into the sea
Sally then arrives on a speedboat with a
modest collection of treasure Alayna
reveals she saved Drake's ring after
Nate abandoned it and the three
literally sail off into the sunset roll
credits so that's you all caught up on
uncharted 1 but if you want to check out
a recap of uncharted 2 keep an eye out
for that video tomorrow